All right. If you're here uh to listen
about detection rules and endpoint for
detection engineers, you're in the right
place. Um yeah, my name is Micahen. I'm
the team lead for the threat research
and detection engineering team at
Elastic. Uh let's get to it. So, you
know, the landscape, uh it's growing
busy. Um there's new tools, there's new
agents, there's uh new SDKs, there's a
lot of things going on by the day. Uh
people are trying out new different
tools all the time. And so um that's
part of the problem, right?
I saw this on Reddit in case you guys
missed it the other day. Someone said,
"Hey, uh I have this extension that I
downloaded and it's trying to connect
silent to live tickets.com." And this
was kind of the scary part. They said,
"Uh very simply, I have no idea what
extension it could be." And uh that's
like the issue, right, for us, you know,
users, they're installing a bunch of
things online um all the time and it's
harder for us to audit them, especially
as people are dropping. Yeah. So users
are installing tools faster and uh it's
making it harder for them to uh be
audited. So yeah.
>> Yep. Your devs are running these uh
right now. So that's again the problem.
They're installing these things, their
tools. They're running the different MCP
servers. They're trying different IDs.
And so yeah, they're all their
endpoints. Like these tools are spawning
shells, they're writing files, they're
making network calls, and the idea is
that your EDR really has no clear
visibility on what's driving it. So a
couple stats here about, you know, how
devs are using them. A lot of code is
being merged by these different tools,
cursor, claw, so on and so forth. Uh, a
lot of heavy users these days, and it's
going to continue to grow. Obviously,
people are using this stuff.
So where do you start? That's like the
big question. You have a bunch of
different data that's coming in. So
where do you start? Especially from a
detection engineer. How do you um how do
you try to triage this? Right? And so
the first thing that uh you know we
recommend is by looking at endpoints by
host count and looking at where all of
the DNS information is going to. So at
the top we have based on some of our
telemetry a lot of data is going to
enthropic chat GBT cloud so on and so
forth. These things make sense. they
seem normal and that's going to be part
of the problem that we talk about in
just a minute here.
The next thing is if you're looking at
the endpoints or the binaries, you can
start looking at code signatures based
on some of our telemetry
um over a small window. For all intents
and purposes, we didn't see many
unsigned code signature binaries. So
effectively from as a detection
engineering perspective you could try to
write a simple rule that says hey if if
uh there is a process then the code
signature doesn't exist or it's false
then you can flag on that but that's
kind of it's going to be weak especially
as you see many of the types of activity
that we've seen is signed and trusted
obviously that stuff makes sense right
um you can start looking at process
ancestry so top processes spawn
biogenide soils you can start looking
there. But then you start to see more
and more of the same kind of problem. U
you see different we've seen different
tools like uh cloud and cursor uh spawn
and git and gh and node and bash and so
on and so forth and uh a lot of the
unsigned ones are buried in that noise.
You have to really sift through the the
data to find these different things. It
gets a little bit even more complicated
when you have these long command lines,
right? when you have these geni tools
which are chaining different multi-piped
uh commands together
right so it's harder for us as detection
engineers to spot these things um file
modification right so that's the next
thing you can start looking at uh
whether geni tools are writing any file
activity but again it kind of gets into
that same theme where we see some ji
tools are they're touching um maybe
config files you see other things that
are being spawned that looks like
they're touching ing just regular PI
files that make sense. Developers are
using tools to create code. So a lot of
that stuff is um you know business as
usual if you will right where we're
concerned about is whether we have these
geni tools touching sensitive files or
or config files and rewriting and
establishing persistence and defensive
invasion techniques. Those things are
all hidden under all this noise of
activity that's being written. Right? So
from a detection engineering
perspective, you could try to say we're
going to monitor file rights to AI
config paths by unexpected processes.
That's one idea you can try to do
from there.
Yeah. So you can take these ideas. So
taking just kind of a step back, right?
You can look at network data, you can
look at processes, ancestry, you can
look at file rights, you can look at a
bunch of endpoint telemetry. We're not
talking about the model provider um uh
artifacts that can be ingested like
guardrails and so on and so forth that
you might get from you know Azure or um
AWS bedrock or you know so on and so
forth but we're talking purely from an
endpoint perspective so at elastic we do
we have shipped a couple rules towards
the end I'm going to show you a couple
links so you can find where we have the
stuff we're open so we do provide these
things availably available today but we
have some uh rules for credential
central access via GI. We have uh ideas
around persistence for GI tools, unusual
DNS calls, suspicious URLs. When you
start looking at some of the data and
some of the alerts that come from those
things, you start to allow us to like go
digger and start pulling and proddding.
We can ask some more targeted questions
like why is a geni tool uh touching a P
list or or why is a you know geni tool
touching some login.json JSON or some
cookies file or credentials file.
So again, that is the problem, right?
The alert fired, a suspicious process
ran. Good luck finding out if it is a
human or an LLM did it, right? Um
looking again at the the presentation we
just saw 5 minutes ago. This is the
problem. We have people who are running
Claude, running their tools, and they're
just executing things on the command
line, and it makes it really hard for
us, right?
So we guys like Rob, they they they give
me heartaches. So
talk about the intent attribution. It's
broken, right? We have the developer, we
have an AI agent, they're executing some
shell, some bash command. And for us, it
looks identical. Nearly identical. The
telemetry looks the same. We have a
process pit. We have a user. They're
running a command, right? Same pit, same
user, same command line. nearly
identical telemetry.
To make things worse, then there's that
bigger threat model. There's prompt
injection techniques. There's malicious
MCP servers. There's there's many
different tools out there that
essentially trying to going from a
threat model. Again, there's many
different threat models. Just to kind of
speed through this, all these things are
hitting AI agents. And let's just take a
step back. Um, we don't know if someone
yoloed, clicked the button, said go do a
thing, and it downloaded a file or hit
the web, hit a website, downloaded a
file, executed it, established
persistence, and then told it to run
some shell command. From for our
perspective, we don't see the intent. We
don't see that from so yeah, the big
problem, right? So, an attacking
position, again, I kind of just alluded
to this, but imagine there's some
poisoned repo file that tricks the AI
agent into exfiltrating some data. um
all through legitimate looking
processes. Again, imagine the developer
that's just yelling. They're clicking
the button, just go go go. I did hear a
call came out with uh like a remote uh
capabilities too where imagine you're on
your phone just hit and go, right? And
so this is this is what we're going to
have to start facing again from an er
perspective. We see cursor helper. It's
a helper tool. We see that saying uh zsh
or some bash command executing curl.
There's no link back to that poison
file. We don't see that context. We
don't see the prompts. We don't see that
natively.
So again, the entire chain looks like
some developer running some malicious
thing, which again you need detection
rules for. But again, tying it back to
some generic tools, it makes it even
harder.
So current telemetry. So what we see, we
see process spawns, file events, network
events, user context. We can tell like,
hey, if something if a route is running
this, maybe it's suspicious. We see some
runtime activity. But moving forward,
there's other opportunities, right? We
can look at what is the prompt, what
what was the prompt? Um what was the
model reasoning behind it? Were there
some shell built-ins? Um let's look at
the MCTP tools or the skills or the um
tools that were all um embedded into the
sh the chain. Um to really try to find
out was it a human versus an AI.
So this is where detection starts to
break down a little bit. I'll kind of
speed through this a little bit. There's
a couple topics here. I won't go into
all of them, but essentially here's a
couple ones just to think about. Think
about from a developer perspective,
people have different sandboxes as
developers. In one chat, you might have
an agent doing another thing. Another
chat, you might have it doing something
else in one workspace or another. How do
we start stitching the context between
these two different sessions um where an
adversary might try to abuse cross
sessions to achieve their end goal? Um
it's kind of one of the problems that
we're running into today, that cross
session loss. And then sandboxing,
right? some pro some sessions, you know,
depending on what you're asking these
tools to do, they may ask you for
permissions. So, the next question is
how do we detect when an AI agent
selfescalated versus a user saying go do
a thing?
Um, so we've seen this a little bit
here, this process ancestry tree here,
this is what it looks like to us or this
is what it should look like. cursor
running cursor help running some zsh um
shell running curl just this is what it
should look this is what it should look
like um so you can see at the very top
we see curl zsh the helper the user with
the developer but we don't see which
prompt triggered it
so getting into some opportunities here
um I I want to talk a little bit briefly
about why that why just a parent process
name is not enough right so if you just
go with the aren't, right? It's going to
catch just that one that one level.
You're going to miss the grandchildren.
You're going to miss that ancestry tree,
especially when it's chaining multiple
commands. You're going to miss the
intent. So, the idea is maybe you might
want to start walking the full ancestry
tree and hopefully it doesn't get too
far down the path.
Um, you can look at entity ID
intersections where you're basically
trying to correlate down the chain again
um between different entities. So you
can try to identify um whether it's a
genary tool or in the ancestry or not.
Again, it's just another idea to try to
uh stitch the children back up to the
parent back up to the grand parent.
MCP server detection just another uh
idea you can start looking at, right?
And so it's uh in some ways you can
today you can say hey there's a command
line that looks like MCP server. You can
as if you're a detection engineer, you
can understand how brittle this could
be, right? And so we're going to talk
about some ideas that we'd like to see
moving forward, but just imagine you can
say, "Hey, this is a MCP server cuz
under this hood, it's all running like
node and some other, you know, um, shell
command, right?" So you can start trying
to write some MCP server like
detections, but what's still missing is
here. We don't know what MCP tool was
invoked. We don't know the identity
trust level, you know, and so again,
it's just it's just not the full
picture.
Uh credential access, I kind of talked
about that earlier. We can do this open
creation modification. Anytime a genai
tool touch uh process touches a
sensitive file, you can try to start
looking at this. You can try to alert
and say, "Hey, is this normal? Why is uh
you know, why is touching your
credentials?
So um at a snapshot we have some rules
we do ship them today again I'm going to
get back to that uh towards the end but
we have some execution some C2 stuff we
have credential access persistence
deficiencation techniques we can start
somewhere that's like the bottom line
here is that you can start you don't
have to wait until uh it's all
instrumented.
Um obviously we might want to start with
you know detection rules versus just
hunting. So, you know, uh the idea is to
obviously use both, but um start by
establishing some hunting queries, use
that telemetry to help build out some
building blocks for you, and then from
there, um use your detection roles to
build out more highfidelity signals.
So, where the industry needs to go,
right? So today's best option is that
process parent name that that that those
heristics really um give us a a a
fighting chance if you will but it's not
good enough.
So here are some gaps right and this is
where you know I'm hoping the industry
starts to lean in forward and go towards
um being able to provide data about the
tool use and decision reasoning natively
making that more native and more
consistent across the different tools.
Right? So that's the key model refusal
events when it says hey I'm not going to
do a thing because of X Y and Z we want
to ingest that as well token level uh
tool call attribution tying that back in
right we already can pull things in from
um the endpoint like what prompt
triggered and I'm going to talk about
that in just a second with hooks but
yeah there's some opportunities and
every production role is quite frankly a
workaround for telemetry that should be
built in natively
and then there's A couple different
risks here. Obviously, you know, as the
more data that you pull in, then you
have to worry about other things.
Compliance and forensics. I'm a
detection engineer, so it comes in the
back of my mind, but uh these are things
that we still have to uh take into
account as we as we keep asking as
detection engineers for more data.
There are agent hooks, right? To no
surprise, um agent hooks is a is a
powerful tool for us where we can look
at pre-tool calls or session starts when
users submitted prompts. we can hook
into those signals and and find the best
way for us to pull out contextual
information to enrich our data. Right?
The if an AI tool did a thing, we hook
into it. We ingest that into open
telemetry and then we push that back to
our seminar edr. That's the big picture.
Um if you're not familiar with um it is
uh just imagine a a common lexicon, a
way that uh the industry should continue
to adopt. who can speak the same
language. That way I don't have to write
a a rule for one vendor and another or
another tool just because they named
their tool call a different field. It
makes it really hard as a detection
engineer to manage all these different
rules. So consistency semantics the same
lexicon it's important for us upstream
that we're we have started that process
at least at elastic. We've worked with
the open cell community to establish
some jai semantics some base fields and
we're going to continue adding there.
We've merged in a couple PRs. We're
trying to shape and shift this. But
again, the more we see people adopting
these things, the better for us. So
that's the vision. Hooks go to hotel.
It's native fields that any edr any um
security solution could ingest.
So we talked a little bit about this. Um
if you do use cloud code, it's one that
already shapes hotel natively. It's a
perk, right? So um whether it's geni
fields or their cloud code fields those
are things that are um are great
enablers if of if these tools are
already adopting them right some other
ones they're still coming along
um and if we get there then what do we
get right so again we have this this
beautiful you know language here or a
set of fields where we know hey this
process parent the tool name was cursor
and this cursor Cursor is the thing that
spawns shell. We know that it was
approved because the user submit
submitted it and here was a provider,
right? We have all this information that
we can attribute back down to whether
this was something that was permitted,
suspicious, anomalous. You get the idea.
And then uh with it all, we we get the
prompt. We get we can ingest obviously
guardrails and the things that those
things provide. pull in the model, pull
in the tool, um, and then, uh, pull all
that information down into one cohesive
like story.
Yeah. And I already mentioned the clock.
It's kind of the exception here.
So, just some quick takeaways here. The
idea is to reduce the attack surface,
right? So, before writing rules, reduce
what you need to detect. That's kind of
like the one of the bigger problems here
is assessing um, you know, your
inventory first. know which tools your
your org should be using, right? Um, you
know, scrutinize run times. Should geni
tools be running as root, right? Should
there be some network controls? There's
this other um approach that uh I don't
hear talked about uh enough about um
deciding on whether your org should just
be browser focused or native focused. It
would make things a lot easier. Um but
you know, obviously that's not going to
work for many developers. But having
some separation of powers is a topic
that should be continually explored. Um
obviously DNS network first. Um we
already have seen in our telemetry how
some firewalls and gateways are starting
to tag data with genai fields and
whatnot. So we know they have the
capability to do that. Um we just want
to speak the same language when we're
ingesting that data and uh bake that
into our rules.
So just to recap, right, it's like a
maturity process. We're going to
continue to grow. Start where you are,
build towards full observability. You
start with the visibility. Those are
some things we can do today. Start
bringing things like guard rails, you
know, network controls on LM rules,
scrutinize root node, and then the
long-term game is that full
observability. That's the thing that
that we're trying to get to.
Yeah. And uh finally, uh if you want to
see some of these rules in more detail,
just take a look at these two different
uh repos here. You can go to GitHub. You
can search for these things here and it
should give you everything you need to
know. You can see some of our endpoint
and our SIM based detections. Um, and
how we do this. Again, we're open so you
can check it out immediately.
And that's it.
Okay. All right. I have a question. What
slideware do you use? Cuz scrolling
within the slide is pretty cool. Well,
what are you using? Yeah,
>> it's like notion and some other
>> notion. Yes.
>> All right. Okay. All right. Questions.
Okay. I got one here. I got a lot of
questions. Okay. So, I'll start here.
Walk my way over there and go over
there. All right.
>> Oh, yeah. In a sorry, in an enterprise,
how do you get your devs to actually do
the agent hooks in the various tooling?
Yeah, it depends on how well your
endpoint if you have an endpoint is
mature. They can roll out a policy that
establishes hooks then that would be the
number one way. I've seen some folks who
are starting to share um internally in
their org skills repos hooks you can
share that say download you can kind of
do that but if you're going for
enforcement then yeah you definitely
want to go the endpoint route
>> kind of using what
>> so if you have an endpoint and it's
hooked into your agent it's installed in
people's agents you enforcement is like
a second nature uh just have it
installed directly into ADR. That's the
idea.
>> Oh, okay. Yeah. You mentioned next
generation firewalls as a potential
source to get more visibility. Um, do
you have a preference on build versus
buy? And are there anything out there
that you would recommend beyond the next
generation firewalls like any inference
level or proxy level data?
>> Yeah, that's a it's a good question. So,
I'm not in the network and firewall
landscape, so I can't speak, you know,
too much on that. Um yeah.
>> Hi. If it's possible, could you quantify
the amount of I guess organizational
resources that you use to I guess roll
this out and uh build and develop this
like maybe the amount of teams or people
um along with like maybe the amount of
months if you're allowed to disclose
>> from the rules perspective or which
part? um more just like getting uh the
telemetry from all of these agents on
all your endpoints to be observable like
how you got that to to be seen.
>> Yeah. So fortunately at elastic we do
have an edr and so there's not much that
we have to do there you know it's out of
the box right you download and solid so
um yeah natively regardless of whether
we have these new geni fields available
we have always been able to get data
around our processes networkers and
files and so that was a great place for
us to start getting to that next level
is is is the challenge
>> hey Mike great presentation as a fellow
detection engineer I have a bit of a
spicy question. If I already have
observability into network activity,
process activity, endpoint, telemetry,
etc., do I really care if it was an
agent or a human?
>> If you already have observability on all
the data, yeah, of course, it's uh it is
the um it's the same. I'll ask you in a
different way. If someone uses GI to put
out AI slop, is that any different than
if they manually put out some slop? Like
you really would want to know what is
behind this. Like is it your developer
who's doing it because doing something
or making decisions because they made a
bad decision or is it because they just
clicked the button and and yoloed it? In
my opinion, I think it's one's a little
bit more riskier than the other.